Can one use things like the right machine or inference on this or PEMF, if you're on different medications, what cancer does it interfere with the effectiveness of the cancer drugs?
So, the right machine and PEMF would not interfere with medications for cancer or cancer drugs or chemotherapy or radiation.
Sonas might. So, sonas increase your body temperature, increase your ability to detoxify and sweat, you will detoxify through your skin with a sona, that's the whole purpose of doing a sona.
And if you increase your detoxification pathways, what you're out of medication, well, it can detox the medication. So, it's going to decrease the effectiveness of the medication you may need more of that medication.
So, I mean, you've got to be aware of that. That's the same thing you've taken a whole bunch of things to stimulate your detox pathways when you're doing a chemotherapy. You could be detoxing the medication.
Or any medication. So, if you're doing any medication and now you, you know, looked into natural things and I'm going to really support detox pathways and start coffee animals and do these inference on us and do all the stuff that's going to be very helpful for me, because it's good to say it's going to be good to help myself detox.
It makes a lot of sense. But if you're out of medication, you do have to factor in that, you know, this ex dosage of the medication that was working for me doesn't seem to be working for me anymore because you are increasing the rate of detoxification.
If what you're doing is actually helping with your detox pathways, it's increasing the rate of detoxification through those pathways. So, you're going to increase the rate of detoxification of that drug.
Whenever everything that you put in your body, that you consume, that you absorb, that circulates in your body has to ultimately be detoxified through your liver phase one to three pathways.
If you're increasing the rate of function of those pathways, then it's supposed to figure that you are going to increase the rate of detoxification of those medications.
And you will lose effectiveness over time, all those medications have a half-life of your body, and you may want to talk to the prescribed doctor.
The rife is not doing that, so the rife is actually, if you're using the rife alongside chemotherapy, actually, in my opinion, help the chemotherapy attack the cancer much more effectively.
I don't have any physical data other than just clinical observation to support that theory, but we just see that over and over again, people that come to us that are doing chemotherapy, they follow us because the chemotherapy was not working well.
Well, we started with the rife, and lo and behold, the chemotherapy started working real well. Now, was it the chemotherapy that was still not working well and the rife was killing the cancer?
I don't know, but it just seems so coincidental that it's almost every single person that was doing chemotherapy prior to coming to us and getting a rife.
The chemotherapy started working better once they got the rife, and maybe thought the chemotherapy is working better. Maybe it's just the rife that was killing the cancer.
But I try to think through physiological processes, what I've tried to decide what will work or what should work or what is working with any clientele.
And it just makes physiological sense to me that when you're hitting the cancer with its own frequency and you're causing it to vibrate, you're decreasing the waist layer around the cancer, it's making it more available for medication like chemotherapy to attack it or even a natural approach to attack the cancer.
It's making it much easier for your own T cells and natural killer cells to attack the cancer.
So if you're doing chemotherapy, and the chemotherapy is having a difficult time getting into the cancer, it's not going to kill it very well.
So if you could improve that, it's going to work better. Certainly if you're going to do chemotherapy, you want it to work and you want to support every way you possibly can to make it work.
The P-MF, in my opinion, will not affect your medication use in any way. Somebody might argue that the P-MF really helps with detoxification.
I don't think so. The P-MF's real benefit is increasing cell charge. The P-MF uses electrical frequencies where the rife uses light frequencies, so the P-MF really isn't affecting the cancer, it's not killing the cancer.
The P-MF's are good tools, so they're great tools for somebody with serious disease. They could help bring energy back to a cell because they help the cell charge.
So one of the problems with cancer is that you'll see a person's cell charge go down, you can measure that cell charge with an instrument that measures what's called a phase angle, that measures the impedance across the cell membrane.
And there's actually studies that show when you lose that cell charge, that cell membrane charge that impedance goes down, the survivability of that patient goes down, well P-MF can help improve that, so it can be very beneficial that way.
Don't think that it appears with any medication stone.